for more on all of it we're joined now
by the former acting and Deputy CIA
director that's Michael Morrell he's
also a CBS News senior National Security
contributor Michael good morning thank
you for being here uh the strategy is
confusing to me why would the defense
minister of Russia wake up on a Sunday
and call four countries and make this
dirty bomb accusation what's he trying
to do
Russia is losing on the battlefield and
so they've turned to psychological
warfare to try to get the West to shake
shake the West resolve with regard to
supporting Ukraine so when they claim
the ukrainians are going to use a dirty
bomb what they're really saying to us is
we might use a dirty bomb and that's
designed to shake that resolve that I
talked about and I don't think it's
going to work because it hasn't worked
before
hey you know hearing you say that I
think the answer to my next question is
a definitive no but I wonder is there
any good in the fact that the Russian
defense minister is at least on the
phone with counterparts in four
different countries
I think it's excellent that the Russian
defense minister is talking to his
counterparts because if we're going to
find a way out of this war it's going to
because it's going to because we're
talking to the Russians so I think
that's actually a very good thing
so I'm interested in the next phase of
the war what might be possible we're
getting to it a little bit Ukraine is
taking back territory particularly in
the South and planning operations uh in
the East what could happen with Russia
striking infrastructure the winter
coming take us if you could to the next
three to six months as best we can tell
sure so what Vladimir Putin is hoping
for is that he can hold on until winter
and if he can get to Winter then the
fighting will die down
um and he can and and the energy crisis
in Ukraine the energy crisis in Western
Europe
um he's hoping will force the ukrainians
to the negotiating table which is where
he wants to get to because he's he's
losing
um what their ukrainians are going to
try to do is both in the Northeast and
in the South
um try to increase the counter-offensive
to gain as much territory back as they
can before winter so expect more
fighting over the next several months
all right Michael Morrell for us Michael
thank you very much